David Ayer would like to be left out of
this whole Joker mess thank you very
much
the Suicide Squad director took to
Twitter to defend himself in the wake of
a report that Jared Leto's role as the
Joker in Suicide Squad was severely
reduced because AR was unhappy with his
performance it's just the latest
development in a strange drama that has
played out after the success of Joker
the hit origin story starring Joaquin
Phoenix according to The Hollywood
Reporter Leto was none too thrilled when
Warner Brothers put a solo Joker film
into production that did not star him
after Suicide Squad made nearly 750
million dollars at the global box office
Leto famously committed to the role some
people like his co-stars might say he
was a little too committed but the
actors reportedly being gifted rats
bullets and dead pigs as part of letõs
method approach to playing the Joker but
letõs depiction of the Joker left many
DC fans unimpressed the fact that Leto
screen time was limited to only about 10
minutes in suicide squads final cut
probably ended up benefiting the film
but if the quality of the actors
performance had anything to do with that
decision the director isn't coming clean
about it in response to a fan who asked
him on Twitter if the report was true
Ayer simply responded this is inaccurate
information not my words or actions th
RS reporting has detailed how Leto was
upset over Joaquin Phoenix's Joker movie
being put into development before either
of his own Joker centric projects a solo
movie for his Joker and a team-up with
Margot Robbie's Harley Quinn had come to
pass he reportedly fumed about the
situation to his agents and allegedly
went so far as to ask one of his
well-connected buddies Irving Azoff his
music manager to put a call in to Warner
Brothers brass in an attempt to get
Phoenix's Joker killed
Joker of course has gone on to make
roughly all of the money while becoming
the most talked about film of the fall
meanwhile both film set to feature his
Joker are now apparently dead in the
water the latest trailer for 2020s birds
of prey opens with Harley Quinn stating
flatly that she dumped - the Joker just
as unceremoniously as Warner Brothers
appears to have done so what are the
chances that Leto will eventually return
to the role well nothing's official yet
and it's worth noting that Leto still
maintains a professional relationship
with Warner Brothers and is currently
shooting the crime thriller little
things for the studio that said we're
definitely thinking that letõs turn as
The Joker will prove to be a one and
done with Joaquin Phoenix's Joker movie
also being widely described as a
standalone project it's possible the
next time we see the Joker it'll be a
whole new actor under the makeup but no
matter who eventually gets recast as the
Joker we know one thing it's got to
happen eventually I think you and I are
destined to do this forever
assuming Jared Leto doesn't sneakily
show up in birds of prey somehow it
seems possible that the next iteration
of the character won't happen until we
get a sequel to Matt Reeves the Batman
set to hit theaters in 2021 that movie
starring Robert Pattinson in the lead
role seems to be packing its cast with
tons of villains from Batman's rogues
gallery but so far we've heard nothing
about a joker appearance with no other
movies featuring the character having
been announced yet
it looks like the live-action Joker
might be resting for a while
but he's not necessarily done with comic
book movies with his turn as Morbius the
living vampire set to debut in Sony's
Marvel Universe in 2020 so as long as he
can keep from mailing dead bats to his
co-stars on that movie he should get
along just fine
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]